[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here and i got a
couple phones three phones i want to
talk about today well four if you
include the iphone but
all three of these phones here that i'm
holding have one
bleeding edge hardware feature that the
iphone has managed to avoid for one more
year so in case you've been living under
a rock and somehow missed it in which
case i would love to check out that rock
but there's a new iphone the whole
iphone 13 lineup just got announced it's
a relatively minor upgrade as i've
mentioned but there's a solid checklist
of things that are new this year
including promotion on the pro phones i
made an entire video summarizing it all
in one place so to get all that info
there's a link right below the like
button for you the iphone
plays it safe with the hardware
notoriously i mean i think it's more
obvious this year than ever so
fresh off the heels of all the people
who have just showed up to the channel
for the first time seeing that iphone i
give you three phones and each one of
them has some hardware feature that is
so bleeding edge that it's actually kind
of a bit risky and there is a reason why
each one of these hardware features
isn't in the iphone yet so i'm going to
go through each of these and if you
don't mind i'm going to reference the
iphone 13 for each of them because the
difference between what apple is doing
with
four new phones per year versus what
some of these other companies do with
dozens of new phones per year
is kind of massive so first up this is
xiaomi's brand new 11t pro xiaomi makes
a ton of phones it actually just became
the number one smartphone manufacturer
in the world in terms of sales and a lot
of their phones have some pretty crazy
hardware this one definitely comes with
a charger in the box
you know why i say that because this is
the charger a massive brick that yes is
going to hit 120 watts at its peak
120 watt
fast charging
it's kind of incredible now that'll take
this massive 5 000 milliamp hour battery
from zero
dead all the way up to 100 percent full
in less than 20 minutes it's kind of
crazy now before we all go down to the
comments to leave your explosion jokes
or your fiery hot takes about how this
will probably nuke your battery life
i've seen a lot of those on twitter and
that's been a common concern but
batteries these days are better than
ever and
i know it's natural to have the concern
that like something that could charge
this fast would probably have just awful
effects on your battery after a year of
use or something like that but xiaomi of
course has considered this they actually
had a slide up during their presentation
for this phone that directly addressed
that showing they expect about 80
battery health after 800 charge cycles
which they say is actually better than
some other flagship phones now i don't
know if i buy that it's going to be
better than other flagship phones but
20 degradation after 800 charges which
for context is about one full charge a
day for two years straight
that's actually pretty good now this is
by no means the first fast charging
phone we've had 45 watt fast charging 65
watts there's a couple hundred watt
phones floating out there
but this is the fastest i've seen yet at
120 watts and for context the iphone 13
is still charging at 20 watts now it's
not for no reason it's not like apple
could easily bump the iphone to 120
watts without trade-offs and they just
don't want to for one this is a split
battery cell for faster parallel
charging which technically does shrink
the total battery capacity a little bit
and you also do generate quite a bit of
heat with this type of voltage so xiaomi
is doing a lot of cooling and a lot of
thermal monitoring to make sure the
phone does this as safely as possible
but i do still believe that the top
reason why we haven't seen this
extraordinarily fast charging in the
iphone yet is still long-term battery
health so my iphone 12 pro that i've
been using since it roughly came out for
about a year is sitting at 95
battery health which is pretty good
after two years that's about 90 percent
and to apple that's a more desirable
feature than super fast charging i mean
this is the company that shipped a 5
watt charger with the iphone up to the
iphone 11 and who would rather throttle
down your cpu speed and make your phone
slower than risk overworking your
battery so it's it's not something i see
them switching up anytime soon and i'm
sure if you ran the numbers most people
do most of their charging overnight
anyway but
you got to admit the sheer convenience
of fast charging is super important and
to people like me who have gotten used
to it it's kind of indispensable it's
amazing having like
knowing you have to leave in like five
minutes and your phone's nearly dead and
you just realize you have to charge it
up real quick and getting like 30 to 40
just like that
is something uh some people will go a
lifetime without knowing about but
because of all the things we've talked
about
overall battery capacity thickness
thermals long-term battery health apple
has decided
yeah 20 watts so all right this
is the zte axon 30. this is a 500
android phone with a snapdragon 870 6 to
12 gigs of ram pretty huge 6.92 inch 120
hertz display and a solid battery with
fast charging but what could this modest
mid-range phone have that the iphones
don't
what was that it's that right there that
is the new second generation under
display selfie camera and it is
way better than the first one so i
recently did a whole video on the first
generation version of this and it was
pretty rough not gonna lie it was still
very visible in a lot of situations
especially with the lighter colors
and the image quality that came from the
camera behind the screen
is just bad it's just foggy and hazy
blurry
not great right
this second generation camera here to my
eye honestly and the camera gets it
pretty well it's nearly invisible like
it's a huge improvement and you can see
it looks like they've doubled the pixel
count and the rectangular cutout so now
objects and sharp text passing through
this area are only mildly pixelated this
time and they even do a great job with
the ui of making sure things typically
don't pass through that area anyway so
it rarely catches your eye during any
sort of regular use
also i believe adding those pixels back
also helps with perceived brightness so
it's legitimately really hard to see
anything back there now the photos it
takes
still pretty trash uh and this is the
part that i wonder how long it will take
to improve because honestly the hiding
it behind the screen part is now
functionally perfect so i wonder how
many more generations it's going to take
to make a
selfie in perfect lighting
not
hazy and soft i mean it's serviceable
it's fine for an average video call or a
basic selfie but nobody would ever say
the quality is really good so despite
the defogging algorithm there's still
blooming in highlights and discoloration
and a lack of sharpness so people who
buy this zte phone today
or the xiaomi mix 4 or the galaxy z fold
3 for that matter are going to be people
who don't care as much about the highest
quality selfies in the world and that
might again be the exact opposite set of
priorities as the iphone which has had
now the largest notch in the entire
smartphone world for a couple years now
because it's got face id and the selfie
cameras up front but this is the first
year that they have actually shrank the
notch on the iphone the iphone 13s
compressed the same face id and selfie
stuff to be 20 smaller this time but it
looks like that's mainly from moving the
earpiece up top and it also looks like
you don't really get any more info on
that extra screen real estate i was
hoping maybe there would be like a
battery percentage up there but looks
like same ideas last year so another
year with a notched iphone
and another year with a bleeding edge
selfie camera behind the display but
that still definitely has its drawbacks
maybe the third generation is when it
graduates from gimmick status to uh
genuinely something we could see other
phones using but for now it's a little
uncommon a little risky and a little
rare but alright last but not least this
is the infinix 0x
this is a really competitive budget
phone that i haven't talked too much
about it's also pretty new and aside
from the pretty squared off sparkling
design that reminds me a lot of a nexus
4 from a couple years ago there's not a
whole lot striking about this phone but
it does have the numbers on paper going
for it and one of those numbers is a 108
megapixel main camera that's right
you've seen it now a bunch the triple
digit megapixel count has made its way
all the way down to a sub 300 phone it
means almost nothing about the actual
quality of the photos coming out of this
phone but it's still pretty impressive
now all the cameras on the iphone 13
lineup this year did take a leap forward
which is pretty sick we've got bigger
sensors all around we've got that sensor
shift image stabilization on the primary
cameras you've got wider apertures i
mean i am really looking forward to
testing these cameras and i talk all
about this in the summary video again if
you haven't seen it check it out and the
review should be in the works shortly
after but apple has stuck with the same
12 megapixel resolution for the rear
camera on the iphone since the iphone 6s
now what i'm not saying is that apple
just needs to jump to a 100 megapixel
camera
no i kind of doubt they'll ever do that
actually but what i am saying is i would
really like to see and i've always been
curious what apple could do with a bit
more resolution this is something i also
wondered about the pixel for the past
couple years with a couple 12 megapixel
primary cameras in a row and it looks
like we'll finally see with the pixel 6
jumping to a newer bigger 50 megapixel
sensor but this isn't just about numbers
this is just about getting a higher dxo
mark score i find those as useless as
anybody else but 12 megapixel photos
from the iphone or older pixels while
they look great while you're looking at
the wide as soon as you zoom in a bit
they start to break down like they look
fantastic full screen which is how you
look at most photos most of the time but
the second you want to crop in a little
bit at all there's not much detail
information to work with and it looks
worse than something higher resolution
also with video if you've ever wondered
why the iphone doesn't do 8k video while
some other phones do 8k video is 33
megapixels per frame so they can't do 8k
video until they jump to at least a 33
megapixel sensor but the higher
resolution cameras is funny enough the
thing i'm least expecting apple to do
anytime soon because if you've noticed
uh every single one of these super high
resolution primary cameras whether it's
this 108 megapixel infinix phone or
this 108 megapixel xiaomi phone or
this 108 megapixel samsung phone they
all do what's called binning by default
so every smartphone sensor is subdivided
of course into a matrix with x amount of
total pixels that's the megapixel count
so the higher your megapixel count the
smaller those individual pixels or photo
sights have to be now in brightly lit
environments that can be fine but in
lower light the pixels are so small that
not a lot of light hits each individual
one and you end up having to really
boost iso sensitivity to make up for it
that introduces noise graininess i'm
oversimplifying a bit but that's the
general physics of it so what they do is
combine typically groups of photo sites
and then without bumping sensitivity you
can take in more light per effective
pixel to get more accuracy and thus
lower resolution in the final picture
but these also happen to be smaller file
sizes too so this infinix for example
does have a 108 megapixel sensor but by
default when you're taking normal photos
they're all been down to 12 megapixels
every time now if you want the higher
detail but also potentially higher noise
shots you can turn on 108 megapixel mode
and most others also have like a special
separate high resolution mode you have
to switch to to shoot the full 100
megapixels so the iphone has just stuck
with their normal
higher individual natural pixel size 12
megapixel sensors so there is definitely
a marketing advantage to being able to
say you have a 100 megapixel sensor and
there is an occasional shot maybe a
landscape where you will get the most
out of having all those pixels and it's
worth it and you can print it on the
back of the phone and run commercials
talking about it but is it actually
worth it i guess the real question is
how often do you actually go over and
switch to the high resolution mode if
you actually have it
i hardly do i'm guessing most other
people hardly ever do and i also think
most people when they realize they're
going to want to crop later just
zoom in or use the telephoto that's on
most of these high-end cameras anyway so
yeah google didn't budge on this for
years all the way up until pixel six
and iphone is still sticking with it how
long they'll do this
only time will tell so yeah those are
some some big phones with some big
numbers and some big interesting pieces
of hardware i also could talk about
foldables which are obviously another
huge hardware risk and that's another
thing apple probably won't jump into for
a long time until it's fully ready but
just wanted to show some things that i
haven't showed on camera yet which is
these three new phones but i'm curious
if any of these are things that you
would want to see in a new iphone is it
fast charging because i feel like that's
the one a lot of people would be most
interested in but let me know in the
comment section below which of these
features you'd be most interested in
seeing in a iphone 14 or 15 somewhere
down the road either way
thanks for watching
catch you in the next one
peace
you